ce matin au marché de valence d'agen
producteurs et revendeurs sont au rendez
vous la plupart des commerçants mettent
en avant les produits de la région et
pourtant cette année au milieu des
melons et des gousses d'ail difficile de
trouver le raisin chasselas de moissac
l'appellation d'origine protégée située
à quelques kilomètres prisés des
consommateurs se fait rare la raison est
simple la récolte est très mauvaise
pour s'en rendre compte il faut aller à
cazes-mondenard dans cette exploitation
alors nous on est sur le bord c'est le
joli une chose comme ça on est jolie à
la 90 % à peu près puisque on a
uniquement deux grappes de belles
grappes chasselas commercialisable or
normalement ne pas ouvrir avoir au moins
une beigne
abendroth sur la taille des grappes
seule année normale une saison perturbée
depuis le mois d'avril avec les gelées
de printemps puis par les fortes pluies
et la grêle
alors les ouvriers agricoles doivent
trier le raisin abîmé avec son label aop
le chef cela est un raisin de table avec
un cahier des charges en plus d'être bon
il doit être beau
voilà ça c'est un réseau isolé qui a
subi les conséquences du gel et l'a
rappelé c'est pas là rappelé la grappe
ne sont pas à développer normalement en
grappe ne sais pas
développés ne sont pas en danger donc on
ne résignent qui est cours desquelles
mauvais structure de grave donc ça c'est
pas un raisin qui qui peut prétendre à
l'appellation chasse au maroc sur les
deux chambres froides que possède cet
agriculteur une des deux était
normalement mais il estime ses pertes
entre 50 et 60% minimum
une conséquence directe sur le chiffre
d'affaires qui fait craindre une hausse
des prix du produit les conséquences
directes va être le peu de volume donc
le consommateur en trouvera moins que
d'habitude ça c'est certain peut-être un
prix un peu plus élevé puisque la loi de
l'offre et de la demande en train de
forcément une augmentation du prix quand
ya très peu ça permettra aussi aux
producteurs de récupérer un petit peu
toutes les pertes qu'ils ont j'espère
que c'est que ces hausses se resteront
raisonnables cette année le raisin
chasselas de moissac à fêter les 50 ans
de son appellation d'origine protégée
un gage de qualité européen